hello and welcome to the seminar I'm
Gavin Ricola I'm a pathologist at
Medical College of Georgia Augusta
University and today I'm going to talk
about human mutation burden challenges
and opportunities of measuring and
interpretation for patient care these
are my disclosures associated with the
content of the talk most importantly I
work for the Medical College of Georgia
at Augusta University and the opinions
expressed during these presentations are
my personal opinions and do not
represent the opinions of kaijin or any
of my collaborators or my employer also
the panels in discussed in this
presentation are intended for molecular
biology applications and not for
diagnosis prevention of treatment of a
disease
objectives for this talk are you
introduced DMV for the people who are
new to the biomarker but most
importantly go the clinical significance
of DMV and then address the challenges
mostly in validating and interpretating
DMV in in the sense of large panels we
are dealing with for comprehensive
genomic testing this is the outline for
today's webinar I want to go quickly
with some basic principles of IO and
then then we will jump into what is tmb
and why are we talking about DMV and
then it then I'll talk a little bit
about our what we are doing in a
clinical setting or a CLIA setting about
validation and implementation especially
focused on wet bench and bioinformatics
still just a little bit background on
immune oncology or cancer we recycle all
the years our understanding of tumor
immunology has vastly increased and now
this very well-known can't see me
recycle provides the framework for how
we can manipulate the immune system to
attack and destroy the tumor cells this
was a major breakthrough maybe a decade
ago essentially there are seven steps
which starts with the release of cancer
antigens can Sandage in presentation
then priming an activation of the the
antigens then most importantly
trafficking the details of the tumors
infiltration of the T cells into the
tumors recognition of the cancer cells
by the T cells and at the end most
importantly killing the cancer cells by
these T cells so this is the cancer in
our immunity cycle which has led to a
major breakthrough in immunology
specially in solid tumors which has
traditionally lacked any major
breakthrough for targeted therapy as
compared to him or other liquid
malignancies
so respect of all the seven different
aspects of cancer immunity cycle
majority of the focus both in the
pharmaceutical as well as a biomarker
world is focused on this one specific
area of and the seventh about the last
part of the cycle which is how can we
kill the cancer cells and if you're
looking at what are the T cells targets
for this particular regulatory antibody
therapy there are multiple of them and
this is just the beginning of the IO
therapy because it we're just exploring
at the beginning of the exploring of all
these different targets because even
there multiple of them the only target
at this moment in time you're talking
about a speedy one and PDL one so apart
from PD one there are multiple image
checkpoints and we said we are really at
the beginning of the immune oncology
exploration especially in solid tumors
so if you want to go through just the
PDL one approvals by FDA in the last few
years four to five years on the
horizontal axis there are different
tumor types and it has really exploded
over the last five years starting from
melanoma in 2014 to pretty much every
other solid as well as a lymphoma being
targeted and approved by fda for
directed drug therapy and these are the
different pharmaceutical companies with
their PDL 1 inhibitor
apart from PT one video one there the
oral global IO landscape has has been
increased in the last few years has been
increasing this is a flight for 2017 in
2018 io 5 points and you can see the
amount of T cell and about other than T
cell based targeted therapies across the
globe so just to go with the number of
targets and in bed and the different
stages of development majority of them
aren't fully clinical but a lot of them
are moving in phase 1 and phase 2 trial
setting especially in 2019 so apart me
as a pathologist and then a lab director
my momma and focuses is identifying the
biomarkers for all these amazing i/o
based therapy so if you just want to
look at the biomarker landscape in the
last few years it's huge and video one
definitely acquires a central space a
big space in this biomarker setting but
what we're going to discuss today and I
want to give you a bigger perspective of
how big the biomarker field is we're
just going to talk a small you're going
to talk about a small piece of tumor
mutation burden or DMB in in a bigger
perspective for IO based biomarkers so
what is T MV or 2 mutation burden it's
nothing but we are looking at are we Cal
calling a number of somatic mutations
per area of the genome these somatic
mutations accumulate all the time in a
distinct from germline and maybe very
tumor and patient specific I'm going to
attach to that towards the end and and
these mutations are expressed with it Y
DNA RNA and get recognized by immune
cells as new antigen so that's the
hypothesis beyond this the hypothesis
for team
a biomarker for immune oncology
why is TM being pardoned I just want to
go to a couple of data points from dr.
hellman say Museum article which pretty
much started our journey into looking at
DMV as a biomarker for immune oncology
so in this clinical trial what they have
done is they looked at Ithaca C of neva
+ EP versus chemotherapy in the patients
who have high timbre mutation burden and
you can see the kaplan-meier with the
difference in the outcome but the most
important part of that again is that the
high human mutation burden was defined
at least n mutations per megabase that
was the first interesting aspect of this
trial but for me as the pathologist and
somebody who is interested in by mark
design and development the critical part
of the whole the trial was the patients
who have PD will expression less than
one percentage would have a high TM be
they had a pretty good response as
compared to the patients who have low TM
be irrespective of PDL one expression
and I think this is was the beginning of
a lot of us look at EMV as a independent
circuit marker for immuno ecology
because all these years majority of the
focus at least in the pathology labs was
on the expression of PDL 1 and in the
both in the trial setting as well as the
post of the approval treatment setting
was PDL one administer chemistry and
treatment design
this graph shows a correlation between
TMP and the objective response rate with
antipodean long video i'll type in 27
different timbre type this is an
accumulative data and you can see that
the high team we definitely have a
better response to PDL 1 irrespective
the PDL one expression a better
advantage or the reason why DMV everyone
is interested in TM is a pan-cancer it
is present in pretty much every cancer
type we will touch base a towards the
end the important thing is it is
different in different cancer types so
but the good thing is it is present in
pretty much every cancer type but the
most important aspect of looking at tmb
is probably this review article in
clinical cancer research which talks
about what exactly is the being where
and how are you looking at so i just
want to quickly go or that the given
perspective of what team b and looking
at the mb especially as it settle get
further for new antigen looks like so
you so when you're looking at t mb and
how to calculate T and B there multiple
ways we can do that we can start looking
at the somatic mutation we can look at
the transcription into mutated on
messenger RNA proteasome tab transfer
prediction binding of MHC complex as
well as a t-cell recognition so these
are the different way you can predict io
response in a tumor cell and what we are
trying to do is we are focusing in a
very small aspect of this just one of
the six ways we can do that and one that
is the calculation of the somatic
mutation by mutation profiling that's
what TM B is there are multiple ways we
can do that we can look at by hold
sequencing whole exome sequencing
receipt and MSI profiling but we even
bypassing that we are looking at the TMB
through gene pals so I just wanted you
to perspective that there are multiple
ways of looking at i/o base response to
interior cells and you're looking at one
small aspect of that YTM be and even the
way we are looking at is not the ideal
way which should be whole genome or
whole exome but it trying to find panels
which can be used as a surrogate for
whole genome and whole exome sequencing
so with that limitation I want to start
how we're dealing with this currently as
I said earlier you just cannot look at
one biomarker it needs an arm next based
approach where you know ecology which
would cover the TMB MSI looking at TILs
gene expression messenger and profile
fusions MHC and new MHC expressions and
new antigens plus microbial profiles so
with this limitation in the mind if we
are just focusing on tmv how are we
looking at the MB so obviously the ideal
approach is whole genome our whole exome
obviously but what are we doing the
major disadvantage of that is obviously
they're more expensive and you can just
have the most expensive way of doing it
for one biomarker the whole rush and the
plan in the lab is to find the best
ideal circuit the whole exome sequencing
which is more cost effective versus
whole exome sequencing but the this
bandage or the challenge associated with
it is we really need a validation for
that
so a couple of challenges which I think
the French of cancer research is trying
to tackle with tmv is number one there's
a definite lack of standardization for
calculation reporting tmb because
different report may measure d me
differently and it's really difficult to
apply that clinically in a setting where
it is being used for different
phenotypes and that is the goal of the
French of cancer research really you
guys can go and read more about that for
Standardization of tmb and then what the
TMB harmonization project is doing is
they're using the very same or similar
sample in space one with the BA in
silicon Alice's as in the face to with
empirical analysis and space through the
clinical analysis hopefully the data the
entire data will be out with the
guidelines what we have done at our
level is we have a small group of twenty
five-plus clinical India's lab both
Sequoia and we have our own TM
evaluation project which we presented at
last amp meeting and in correlation data
for Team B on a smaller panel so and as
introduction to TM be the summary is it
is one of the most sought out by mark of
this decade and I'll back up that
comment in the next couple of slides it
is turning out to be one of the most
expensive biomarker because of the ideal
of the gold standard method of whole
genome and whole exome sequencing a
majority first think that this is very
much industry driven because
this came out of clinical trials in a
retrospective analysis setting rather
than prospective and and there's so much
complicated algorithms in calculated tmb
and there's somewhat non-transparency
associated with that that has made us a
lot of uncomfortable with it we
personally think that it's at least
discussed we hear we hear about it here
and there but it's not one of those
markers where everyone knows about it
and very clear for everyone to how to
use that we're biologically I think one
of the true challenge with tmb is a
biomarker is it still a surrogate it's
not a the best way to calculate new
antigens in in IO based setting it's
still a small puzzle for near antigen
and but as of now it's the most
impactful biomarker in immune oncology
so this brings you the most important
question is to tmv or not EMV anything a
lot of labs are struggling with this
question because there's a clinical
request and sometimes demand for having
TM be on your panel and if your panels
are not adequate enough there is a
challenge to send out those samples to a
bigger panel just to get the TMV value
- in my personal opinion I think yes we
will have to do tmb for 3ds and it is a
great surrogate of marker or IO new
antigens the trial data at least the
progression-free survival looks great
and the most importantly it's a good
start
for patient selection versus a blinded
patient selection for IO based therapy
and we have seen the patients who have
really high DMV they respond very well
to IO based therapy irrespective of PDL
one as a biomarker so let's move for to
the challenges associated with
evaluation of DMV as a biomarker so I'm
going to go for a couple of them in
detail ways so that we know if we decide
to adapt the invisible marker how or
what's the best way to deal with it one
of the biggest challenge when we as a
lab we faced was what's the ideal panel
size we should be using for calculating
DMV for clinical use I think there is a
good data and evidence for that now a
couple of papers but I think the ideal
size is between one point one to two
point two megabase and also the content
of the panel definitely matters the
second and most important challenge is
the biometrics module for DMV
calculation and this plays a very
important role because a lot of these
calculators with DMV come from
commercial sources either they're coming
out of trials or different validation
five points and and sometimes they made
the FIR with the TMV scores on the same
samples but for me the most critical
part is the clinical interpretation of
the TMV score of the TMV value what
exactly
DMV hi what is the mb low and how do we
need to interpret for clinical decision
making
so this is a nice article from friends
of cancer research which goes over most
of these challenges starting from the
sample collection to the TMB score and
we'll go to them a couple of them so
that we are aware of what they are at
least in a true clinical CLIA lab
setting so one of the biggest challenge
is the tumor type and the sample type
but you really have to understand that
tmb is not a universal signature
biomarker it is very patient specific
and a tumor specific there are tumors
which are cold 40mb in the tumors which
are hard for DME like lung
adenocarcinoma or melanomas which a
value may be really high for them but if
you have let's say a breast carcinoma or
a prostate or Vampira carcinoma for them
a value of five DMB might be a high
which might be low in melanoma a tmb
value for the exact same specimen will
change if the specimen as is it in FFP
sample of formalin-fixed per sample or
it's a fresh sample it's coming from a
cell-free DNA and that is related to the
mutations which are introduced during
the process of formally in the fixation
and we have seen with our experience
with sarah care samples control samples
with the with multiple cell line based
validation that the TMV values are
definitely change even on the same
starting material if if it's fresh
versus FFP then the most important
challenges if you Kimmel especially if
it's coming from FFP you have to do with
tumor enrichment otherwise the normal
humor normal tissues surrounding the
humor will definitely dilute the
mutation profile and you'll get a low
tmv score the second challenge is tumor
heterogeneity 40mb depends especially if
you're working in on core biopsies you
will get a different TMP values if the
core biopsies are from different regions
of the tumor sample the second issue we
are dealing with is is it the panel
which are using for calculating the TMV
as a surrogate for whole exome
sequencing but I think at this moment
there is a general consensus about what
should be the size of these genomic
regions which I use rather than the size
of the panel it should be somewhere
between 1.2 to 2.2 mega base you really
have to think and work on the content of
the panel because there also matters and
entered and the most important thing is
the sequencing which are going to do for
these panels that the platform's
definitely play a role what's the depth
of sequencing what are the
the final calculations are the final
mutations in the panel that are
contributing to mV calculations so these
are the different aspects of the panel
sequencing and the content of the panel
will make changes towards the TMV value
this was a very nice article from a
pathology group in Europe which looked
at multiple panels and and compared them
with whole exome sequencing and came to
conclusion that as a size of one point
two to two point two mega base is ideal
surrogate for all exome sequencing
especially for calculation of a good tmb
and in the lower zero to ten or ten to
twenty mutations per megabase range
so to summarize I think the 1.20 1.12
2.2 mega base size is ideal for timba
calculations
the third aspect apart from the panel
and the content is the five-point
parameters 50 MB calculation what type
of five-point your lab is using for
calculating the TMV most important is
the status of the trim line via variance
how and what data base the pipeline is
using we get rid of the germline
variants makes definite definitely
affect the outcome of the TMV value what
is how much of the deductions driver
mutation happened how many and what are
the variant callers are used to call
these missense and somatic mutations
what is the Lee frequency and what's the
kenapa sorry frequency these are all
different important aspects of the
pipeline you have to consider and look
and pay attention when deciding what
type of a pipeline calculator you want
to use for calculation of tmv for your
panel I'm just going to go over a couple
of slides with our experience with EMV
calculation and validation in our lab
currently we have 170 gene panel which
we use mostly for clinical purpose it's
small in size are less than 0.6 megabase
we have worked and validated the chi
seek 486 gene panel as well as the years
of 500 gene panel tmb
values on these panels so and we have
worked with multiple variant callers and
apps to identify both the mutations
snv's and in Dells and look at the TMV
calculated by these different pipelines
to one of the earlier panel which we in
the lab which we have validated for
clinical use was at est 170 170 gene
panel and one of the challenge with that
panel is the size was really low this
was not a panel of design to calculate
EMU was mostly a comprehensive genomic
panel and you can see that the overall
correlation with foundation medicine was
okay but when you go and dive down into
M V score of 50 mutations from wagon
base the correlation really is lost so
as I really said that the size of the
panel definitely matters when looking at
the TMB value especially in that lower
zone of ten to thirty or ten to twenty
which are critical especially in non
small cell lung carcinoma
our second panel which we worked on was
the guy seek DMV panel which was on 486
teams and around 1.4 mega base the
content of the panel I think was was
very impressive and as I said it's just
not the size of the panel matters but
the content and the genes which are
which should contribute to different
aspects of cancer immunology or immune
oncology and and the pathways which are
associated with antigen presentation
machinery and MHC components which
really helps with getting a good eme
value from the panel and this is a game
going back to the clinical cancer
research review which covers all these
different aspects of Io response
especially the TT antigen presentation
for the CTL I think that's where I have
been very careful about panel selection
and in the content of the panel for Team
B calculation
so some of the earlier work from the TMV
panel was really good when we looked at
the whole exome sequencing versus the
decadent EMV panel the correlation was
really good both on the individual
sample as well as across all tumor type
really good positive predictive value as
well as negative predictive value with
the whole exome data for that panel but
when you get these panels in the lab you
really have to treat tmv as an
independent biomarker it cannot be
rolled into an existing panel because
you have to validate in DMV as a
separate biomarker in your pal so we
went through this exercise based on the
CEP and AM guideline so you you have to
take you buy a marker your panel and go
through the vet bench evaluation
pipeline evaluation and then the
evaluation of tools for interpretation
reporting the data now there are
guidelines to validate amp and CPI
guidelines to validate the NGS oncology
panel and these these guidelines can be
used to validate tmb there are some
additional New York State Department of
Health guidelines especially for NGS and
oncology and I think this is this was
the first official document which talks
about how to validate EMV and MSI I
would encourage people who are new to
this to do this document and see what
the sample type and sample size they
would like but if you're validating any
any new biomarker or new panel in NGS
lab for me personally there four
important core aspects the sample prep
library preparation sequencing and data
analysis and each and every component of
this and
this testing plays important role to get
a better kinda clean consistent data in
a CLIA setting and in all of them have
equal proportionate rule and you need to
spend equal amount of time in all these
four components during validation but if
you're an advanced in this user if you
know your library preparation is good if
you know your sequencing platform is
solid then I would spend a lot of time
in the sample prep and data analysis
because those are the two critical
aspects which can definitely make a huge
difference in outcome data outcome
because what we have seen in our lab and
our experience based on more than 10
comprehensive genomic panel validation
is a garbage in garbage out you really
have to be careful with the earlier
sample prep or pre-analytical QC and
some of the steps which I've lined out
something as simple as you have to make
sure that one of the sample type you're
validating what the procedure form is
the sample is taking because sometimes
the bone marrows that be calcified and
cytology FM is that collected in a
different material and then one of the
most important aspect is looking at a
teeny and making sure you have the tumor
sample as a starting material not just
some necrotic material or even benign
tissue and then most importantly a
hundred percent of for a sample in our
ng slam do get macro dissected and we do
tumor enrichment to make sure that
whatever values we are getting is is as
fortunate to hundred percent of human
enrichment
so this is just a good example of the
kya guys he get the Ambu panel
validation we did we used on sixty
sample from different tumor types
different biopsy dives and and and then
different sample types to make sure that
all of these either they're affecting or
not affecting towards calculation of
snv's and else which contributes to the
team and what we're doing was we were
looking at multiple orthogonal methods
again this is more of a validation for
the CMV than in Dells and then we
definitely contribute to it the TMV
value so as a part of the bigger
validation for NGS you really have to go
through a thorough process and on sample
selection and as many of the samples you
can use which have an orthogonal method
which is being as an IV D that
definitely adds substantial value to
your validation and this is just a
sample matrix we used for one of the
panels including the Kaizen team
- - just to focus on the TMB validation
and evaluation as as you all know all of
genome sequencing and whole exome
sequencing definitely the gold standard
but the approval for the foundation when
CDX is we also use that as a clinical
reference
unfortunately the foundation when panel
size is is less than one mega base which
it's still below than the ideal 1.2
Megabass which we would need to
calculate MB but we have been using
foundation 1k samples and it can be
value as a clinical reference for
validation
so I just want to show you some data on
the guy ck-mb panel validation we did
thorough validation 14 BMS I CMV snv's
NFL for two sides and multiple samples
and then the goal here was to evaluate
the manufacturers analytic claims about
all these different biomarkers the data
I'm going to show is mostly tmb focused
so this was a to side correlation in
between site 1 and side to this adjust
the TMV
and you can see that this is a critical
zone of 10 to 30 mutations per megabase
which is really a critical or a lot of
the hot tumors for him in oncology and
we had really good correlation between
the two sides and the correlation
between foundation 20 me and a guy sick
Team B coalition was also good again in
that in the lower zone of 10 to 30
mutations per megabase
so coming back to the original
discussion of the challenges in tmb said
the size of the panel definitely makes a
huge difference it has it needs between
1.2 and 2.2 the band somatic modules for
Team B calculation you really have to
understand what is included what is
excluded for the calculator of T and B
but for me the most important aspect of
team B is the clinical interpretation of
tmv school and DMV Valley what exactly
is the MD hi DMV low and this really
needs to be defined in a particular
tumor type setting or even a patient
time because if you just look at the
different clinical files and the tumor
type these are the different trials in
which DMV was used as a biomarker feel
the different companies of the drugs
this is a tumor type then again the
question becomes what was the platform
in that particular tumor type was used
to calculate TM B and again most
critical part is what is the true cutoff
in that particular to trial or tumor
type and this is extremely essential
because you cannot have one test to
calculate him before each and every
cancer because that that that value of
DMV might not be applicable to all of
the tumor types and and maybe not
applicable to your patients
so this is this is a really good article
from Zahir and which looks at all the
timber piping and going back to my
original discussion that Tim PMB
signature is definitely not universal
it's rather tumor and and I think we
need to we'll discuss that it's very
patient specific so if you're looking at
these different tumors and they're
mutational burden and you can see there
are a lot of cold tumors and there's a
lot of hot team or some melanoma bladder
cancer tend to be inherently having high
tumor so for these tumors type which are
hot humors a value of 10 mutations per
megabase might be a high but if you're
looking at the coal tumors like germ
cell tumor or a soft tissue sarcoma for
them a value of even the five mutations
per megabase might be high so having a
one cutoff for a band cancer tumor type
it's not ideal so the interpretation of
the TMV score is low and high needs to
be done in a setting of a phenotype or
tumor type and a patient specific so if
you're looking at even if you're looking
at bladder cancer you can see that
different aspect in Ambala cancer
themselves with a patient specific that
can change the TMV signature at EMV
value or score in that particular
patient type so just to give you an
example from the earlier chart let's say
if you're looking at one of the trials
from BMS on Nebo tech made 2 6 3 the
tumor type was first-line non-small cell
lung carcinoma you have to remember that
platform which was used in this protocol
trial was whole exome sequencing and the
way the cutoff for tmb in this
particular trial was low medium and high
these were just number of mutations
in this particular trial and then this
is the particular drug and this is the
particular trial so each and every value
of the TM be calculated at the end of
your conference genomic panel
irrespective of what panel platform
calculator you're using the
interpretation the clinical
interpretation and utility needs to be
done in a setting which is very specific
for that particular phenotype and
patient and then then you can go each
and every phenotype a trial has a
different platform as well as different
cut-offs for a high low end and
intermediate DMB value
so going back to my original discussion
slide on the review from clinical cancer
research about how there are different
methods of looking at i/o response our
new antigens in 'man oncology I want to
I want to highlight the important
limitation that we are looking at one of
the many ways we can do this which is
looking at the TMB or somatic mutation
and most importantly we are using a
surrogate to the gold standard which is
whole genome sequencing and whole exome
sequencing with that I would like to say
thank you for lab boots for organizing
this webinar and then and gaijin' for
helping us reach and discuss this
important biomarker in a setting where I
think we need to talk a lot more about
this in a clinical setting and these are
some other people in my lab which make
all this work possible and thank you
I'll be happy to take any more questions